the logic behind our calendar is that it
is a good
solar calendar well what do we mean
by a good solar calendar well uh
calendar makers will tell you that a
good solar calendar is a calendar
such that on the same
day of every year the sun
rises in the same place against the
background
of the fixed stars this is what we mean
when we say the sun
is in aries we mean that at dawn
the constellationaries is blotted out
by the helical light of the rising sun
but the sun is this
solar masculine
apollonian archetype
it is the archetype of the ego
as god it is the archetype
of the center the unity solar calendar
is
set up so that we do not have what is
called a precession
a precession is where the days slip
against the background of the fixed
stars
our the notion of our calendar is that
it is an agricultural calendar
and we want our great agricultural
holidays to
always fall in the times of harvest and
planting
so a solar year must be used but
what this does is it has an underlying
assumption which is
false and which is has been inculcated
into our psychology with
two detrimental ends and it is this
that this obsession
with fixing the solstices and the
equinoxes against the fixed stars
is the effort to build a structure
on the very largest level the level of
the planet itself
to build a structure that is fixed
that is enduring and the great pride of
our calendar
is that we say it does not slip
that means it's fixed and enduring well
you may not know that the reason it
doesn't slip is because there's a
fudge factor in it
we're all familiar with the fudge factor
of leap year
that every four years we have to add a
year to keep it okay
but how many of you knew that
every century year divisible by
400 is also a leap year
even if it occurs out of sequence the
year 2000 will be
such a leap year it is a
century year divisible by 400
so was 1600 and so in that case you have
a leap year even though the previous or
the following year may be a leap year
so there is a fudge factor in the high
and mighty
solar paternal calendar that keeps it on
track
well somewhat facetiously what i
propose at least as a thought model is
an entirely different
year length 384 days
now 384 days is an interesting number
it's 13 lunations
precisely 13 lunations
and so we would have therefore
a need for a 13th month
in the calendar and i propose that the
13th
month follow august and precede
september
and be called remember and
the month of remember will be a month
of great mnemonic celebration
and recovery of the past
it will be a celebration of the past
well okay now we have 13 months that's
wonderful but
we have purchased this 13th month at the
expense of 19 days
that overshoot the solar year
what about that well instead of viewing
that as a problem as it has always been
viewed
let's view it as an opportunity what
happens
if you use a day length 19 days
longer than the solar year well it means
that the great
festivals of the solar year
easter christmas the fourth of july
will let's call it independence day so
we don't confuse ourselves because it's
gonna move
that these great festivals
will do what is called precess
each year they will come 19 days later
against the solar year than the year
before
so in such a calendrical system
you would be as a child christmas
would occur let us say in winter
by the time you were in your middle
teens christmas would be occurring in
springtime
by the time you were in your mid-20s
christmas would be occurring
in high summer and in your mid 20
30s it would occur again it would occur
in autumn
and through a life of 60 or 70 years
the solar festivals would migrate
through the seasons well this may seem
trivial
to you and hey it may be
but uh the
the psychology of it is
that it's trying to build in at the
highest
level a truth which we have lost sight
of
which is the idea that everything flows
that everything is impermanent that
flux is the only uh
standard flux is the only thing you can
depend on
if we gave ourselves permission at the
highest
and deepest psychological level the
place where we measure time
and the spectacle of our life as spread
out against
the grid of the history that we lived
through
if we were to give that permission to be
portrayed on a grid that emphasized
flow transience change
and recursion rather than this
constipated solar square
against the fixed stars then
what we are really doing you see is
changing archetypes
we are changing archetypes and what are
we changing
we're changing the apollonian solar
paternalistic
dominator archetype for the feminine
oceanic intuitive
giving and taking archetype
of flow and life and death
and completion through change
rather than completion
which seeks to stave off change and then
is inevitably swept away
and therefore somehow touched with
pathos
[Music]
you